Professor David Blight:
The person whose writing drew me
into the Civil War--and I
confess--was Bruce Catton.
Have any of you ever read any
of Bruce Catton?
Ah.
It's a dwindling number in the
twenty-first century.
But when I was growing up Bruce
Catton was the great narrative,
popular historian--or popular
narrative historian--of the
Civil War.
He wrote some seven books or
so, from the late 1950s through
the 1960s into the '70s.
He wrote them around the time
of the Civil War centennial.
He was not an academic
historian, he was a journalist
and a former war correspondent
in the Second World War,
and the man had a beautiful
sense of narrative.
This is Catton from his book
Terrible Swift Sword,
which is 1862,
the year of 1862 of the Civil
War.
He's trying to capture the
situation, the strategic
situation, the emotional,
sentimental situation,
the mood of already war-weary
America, a little more than a
year into this thing;
which is where we're going to
go, and a little bit further,
in a moment.
He's talking,
though, essentially,
about the most important
argument I think we can make
about that first year,
year and a half,
into the second year of the
war.
Both sides wanted a limited war.
Remember that.
On the Confederate side they
just wanted to fight long enough
to make the North or the Federal
Government acknowledge their
independence.
The longer the thing went on,
the more dangerous it was,
of course, for the Confederacy.
They were out-manned,
out-numbered,
they had lesser resources,
et cetera.
On the northern side,
it was the stated policy of the
Lincoln Administration to keep
this a limited war;
and a great deal more on this
next week when we deal with the
emancipation story.
The whole idea again,
for Lincoln,
was to keep this from becoming,
as he put it,
a remorseless revolutionary
struggle.
That is exactly what it had
become by the summer of 1862.
And here is Catton's
description;
I can't do it any better:
"There was nobility in the idea
that there ought to be a peace
without victory.
By August of 1862,
America's tragedy was that it
was caught between the madness
of going on with the war and the
human impossibility of stopping
it.
Secession had been a direct
result of the outcome of the
Election of 1860.
To restore the status quo would
be to assume that either the
North or the South had had a
great change of heart,
that the North would not again
go Republican,
or that the South would quietly
acquiesce if it did.
Neither Mr.
Lincoln nor Mr.
Davis was going to assume
anything of the kind.
Each man was fighting for a
dreadful simplicity.
Neither one could describe a
solution acceptable to him,
without describing something
wholly unacceptable to the
other.
Neither man could accept
anything less than complete
victory without admitting
complete defeat.
Both sides had heard the
trumpet that could never call
retreat.
The peacemakers could not be
heard until the terrible swift
sword had been sheathed.
But the scabbard had been
thrown away and now the
Confederacy was carrying the war
into the enemy's country."
Well, "never call retreat" is
of course a very warlike
language, but this was an awful
and horrible war.
Now Lincoln,
of course--and you've read now
some documents on this,
and if you've started to watch
the Ken Burns film series,
which by the way is now up on
the Classes Server,
it is up on the Classes Server;
well no it's up on CDigix but,
as Sam Schaffer just informed
me, if you go to the Classes
Server there is a
message--what's it called--under
Information?--and under
Announcements,
it tells you exactly again how
to use the URL.
Have any of you already tapped
in?
Okay.
Make sure you watch episodes
two and three,
through the one entitled
"Forever Free," maybe by this
weekend, certainly by the
beginning of next week.
At any rate,
in that film series you'll see
that Burns chose to make George
B.
McClellan a kind of comic
relief--his vanity,
his arrogance,
his insubordination,
his almost incredible,
if complex, hatred of Abraham
Lincoln, Edwin Stanton and all
the leadership of the Federal
Government that he was
commanding the Army for.
Lincoln wanted a strategy in
the wake of Bull Run,
the disaster at Bull Run that
summer, in July.
He puts McClellan in charge of
the Army of the Potomac,
as I said the other day.
McClellan takes them into huge
encampments all around
Washington, DC,
and began in August,
September, October,
and through the fall,
to drill this Army,
train it.
And they came to love him;
that is, all these green,
young soldier boys from all
over the North,
and they were arriving now in
whole new regiments,
week after week after week,
all formed in local communities
across the North.
The vast, vast,
vast majority of them had never
shouldered any kind of musket in
their lives except possibly in a
local militia,
and only a tiny percentage of
them had ever been in a militia.
They actually grew to kind of
love McClellan at first because
he held great parades,
great parades.
He made them march like hell
and train like hell and learn
how to march sideways and
forward and backward and retreat
and do all that stuff.
But man, when he held a parade
it was cool.
They also hadn't seen any war
yet.
He didn't move the army.
Lincoln wanted him to move it
that fall, go back into
Virginia, go find that
Confederate Army again,
find it on the right ground
somewhere, attack it,
end the war.
Not going to happen.
This young, 35-year-old general
was a very cautious soul.
"Who would've thought that I
would be called up to save my
country?"
said McClellan.
And we have those amazing
letters he kept writing to his
wife, over and over and over.
"I am called to save my country.
These buffoons in Washington
don't know what they're doing.
Stanton is an idiot."
And at one point he called
Lincoln "a baboon."
That actually got into the
public.
He was also--make no mistake,
and it's very important,
especially when we get into
'62--he was a pro-slavery
Democrat.
He was the farthest thing you
could imagine in the Union Army
from an abolitionist.
McClellan wanted nothing to do
with the remorseless
revolutionary struggle.
He did not want to move huge
armies into Virginia or into the
South, into densely populated
slave areas, because he did not
want to destroy slavery.
He saw that as a revolution no
army could somehow control.
He even wrote that fall to a
democratic congressman and said,
"You must help
me"--quote--"help me dodge the
nigger";
which was the way he put it.
By January, Lincoln was
impatient, to say the least.
McClellan caught typhoid fever
and was really quite sick for
most of a month and refused to
even answer Lincoln's messages,
at times.
This President of the United
States, the Commander-in-Chief,
is sending him messages,
couriers, and for days
McClellan wouldn't even answer
him.
And then there's the famous
message that Lincoln sends in
February, I believe,
of '62;
sends a message to McClellan
and says, "General,
if you're not going to use your
army, might I borrow it?"
Let's move out West,
as the war is going to break
out all over the West,
whether anybody wanted it to or
not, whether anybody planned it
or not.
I'll get the outline back up
there in case you
didn't--sorry--get to see it.
I don't know if you can see all
this in the back row but I hope
you can see enough to understand
that what we have here is the
region of Alabama,
Mississippi,
Tennessee, Kentucky and over
into Missouri,
Arkansas and so on.
The war broke out in the West
and is essentially a river war,
a river war for the Tennessee
and the Cumberland Rivers in
Tennessee.
Now you only need to look at a
map with one eye open to
understand how important
Tennessee would be in this war.
If Kentucky has still not
seceded from the Union,
and officially will not,
and if Kentucky remains any
kind of buffer for the Union,
Tennessee is where the war is
going to be fought,
in the West,
certainly at first--and it
surely was.
Now, at first the war in the
West was essentially fought with
gunboats, little ironclad
gunboats, and armies on the
land.
But the first major conflicts
in the West were to try to hold,
on the side of the Confederacy,
and to take,
on the northern side,
two forts, one called Fort
Donelson and one called Fort
Henry;
one on the Cumberland,
one on the Tennessee River.
These rivers were terribly
important for transportation
now, especially military
transportation.
They flowed down to Nashville,
one of them.
The other flowed southward and
then into Northern Georgia.
These rivers would be invasion
corridors, if you like,
invasion paths for the Northern
armies.
They were extremely important
for supply and transportation,
for the South.
And hence these relatively
small forts that guarded these
two rivers suddenly became the
focal point by February 1862.
The Union forces that would
attack Fort Henry first,
and then Ford Donelson,
were commanded by a young,
only in his early forties,
General who had been promoted
rapidly from Colonel,
named Ulysses S. Grant.
Now Grant, as many of you may
know--well, Grant has had a huge
revival in scholarship in the
last, oh, two decades.
He was for a long time all but
forgotten in American history,
partly because his presidency
was so awful--and we'll deal
with that later on in the
course--or in some ways so
awful.
He got miserably depressed and
took to drinking--that part's
true--when he was stationed way
out in California in the
late-1850s.
He was a bit of a drunk in
those years and he resigned from
the army.
He'd been a veteran of the
Mexican War, decorated,
but he quit the army,
bored,
depressed, and he went back to
Illinois, his home--well born in
Ohio but he went back to
Illinois--and he was working,
as the story goes,
it's not a legend,
in his brother's leather shop
in Galena,
Illinois when the Civil War
broke out.
And because he was a West Point
graduate and the only one
around, they named him Colonel,
and he led the regiment that
was formed from that area of
northwest Illinois,
and off to war went Ulysses
Grant.
Ulysses Grant is a classic
example--and I want to give you
an illustration of this--a
classic example of an American,
or an American male,
for whom most of the rest of
life, business,
profession--except for
horseback riding,
and he was a hell of a
horseman-- almost everything
else in his life had been a
failure or near failure or
simply boring.
He'd grown up on farms but he
hated farming.
He's a classic example of how
sometimes war,
tragically or unfortunately,
can make a person.
Were it not for the American
Civil War you'd have never heard
of Ulysses S.
Grant.
This is Bill McFeely's
description;
William McFeely who has written
the finest biography of Grant I
think still ever done,
although there've been many
since.
And he's describing Grant's
situation in Galena and how
bored he was and depressed he
was and so on.
And then McFeely writes:
"War, the ordinary man's escape
from the ordinary.
It was a way out of a leather
store, and for some men it is
much more than that,
it is the fulfillment that the
world will yield in no other
manner.
For these men,
war appears as a refutation of
evil, whether it be the evil of
Hitler's threat to Marc Bloch's
France or the slaveholders'
threat to Thoreau's America,
or less exalted but no less
real, the evil of personal
hollowness.
War, for a man like Ulysses
Grant, was the only situation in
which he could truly connect to
his country and countrymen and
be at one with them and himself.
Grant did not like the
vainglory of victory or the
drama of high strategy or the
blood of battle,
and he did not think that all
wars were worth fighting,
yet some essential part of his
being was brought into play only
in war.
He never celebrated this fact,
but neither did he deny it.
He knew it was true.
Only in war,
and possibly at the end of his
life in writing about the war,
in what would be the greatest
memoir of this war,
did he find the completeness of
experience that when engaged in
it so intensely moved him."
Well, Grant was a soldier and,
not unlike Robert E.
Lee, he did enjoy the spirit of
battle;
I don't think there's any doubt
about that.
And he moved on these forts,
first Fort Henry,
February 6, with about 15,000
men on land and a bunch of slow,
cumbersome gunboats.
Fort Henry was not well
defended and basically just
surrendered.
A week later on the other
river, the Cumberland,
Fort Donelson was shelled into
submission by artillery.
This was the second week of
February 1862,
and Grant famously demanded an
unconditional surrender from
General Simon Bolivar Buckner,
who had been Grant's roommate
at West Point.
There's a wonderful exchange of
their dispatches that you can
read if you want to look it up,
easy to find.
Grant writes to Buckner and
says, "Hello friend,
you will surrender all of your
forces and all of your guns or I
will move on you immediately."
And Buckner writes back and
says, "Well now,
well now Ulysses,
can we talk?"
Grant writes back and says,
"No."
[laughter]
And of course the press will
pick this up;
U.S.
Grant will become
"Unconditional Surrender" Grant.
The significance of Forts
Donelson and Henry were not only
symbolic, because the Northern
press picked this up,
waiting for war--God,
months and months and months
had gone by since Bull Run.
There'd been various
engagements.
The armies were growing all
over the country.
Men were going off to war and
writing letters home to their
mothers, sweethearts and
families.
Here was some real war and some
Union victory and a hero.
Most importantly,
strategically though,
the city of Nashville,
capital of Tennessee,
had to be abandoned by the
Confederates;
they could no longer defend it,
and they did abandon it.
It was partly a strategic
retreat and partly out of the
reality they didn't have enough
people to defend it.
And a Confederate Army
beginning to grow now--and this
is into the spring of 1862--as
thousands more southern boys and
men would leave those farms,
in hundreds of regiments from
Mississippi, Alabama,
Louisiana and Texas in
particular.
They will come to join the Army
of Albert Sidney Johnston who
led the small Confederate Army
out of Nashville,
down southwestward into
Southwest Tennessee,
just across the border to the
town of Corinth,
Mississippi.
And it was around Corinth,
Mississippi,
in the northeast tip corner of
the State of Mississippi that a
huge Confederate army was
assembled.
Now, Grant was now put in
command of all Union forces,
all over Tennessee.
Grant, though,
had no idea,
really, what the Confederates
were going to do,
and what happened at the Battle
of Shiloh was not only the first
major horrible,
bloody battle of the war,
and it would shock the country,
but it was a total surprise to
the Union forces.
Put simply, here's what
happened.
Albert Sidney Johnston had
about 40,000 troops at Corinth,
Mississippi,
and Grant had at his disposal
about 60,000 troops.
These are still not the size of
the armies that will begin to
unfold in the East in Virginia.
But Grant had his army split in
two, and widely apart.
About one-third of it was under
the command of a general named
Don Carlos Buell,
and he was in central
Tennessee, Grant's forces were
sort of more western Tennessee,
and both were slowly trying to
move down toward southwestern
Tennessee and maybe even into
Mississippi to find this
Confederate Army,
in March and early April of '62.
What happened was that Albert
Sidney Johnston attempted a
surprise attack,
and it was one of the most
successful surprise attacks by
these large unwieldy armies that
ever happened in this war.
He marched his men twenty
miles, most of it in darkness,
with all kinds of clothing and
burlap used as muffling on the
wheels of caissons and wagons;
even men were told to put
muffling on their boots.
And they marched through night
in the dark, April 5 to 6,1862,
north from Corinth,
across the border into
Tennessee, and they attacked a
remnant, a sizeable remnant,
of Grant's forces that had just
reached a place called Pittsburg
Landing, or Shiloh Church as
it's known--it's a tiny little
village.
And what happened on the first
day at Shiloh was the bloodiest
day of the war until that point
in time.
Grant's troops were literally
caught with their pants down.
They had no pickets out,
they had no idea where the
Confederate Army really was,
nor especially that they were
that close.
There are many famous
descriptions of this in
soldiers' letters and diaries,
and afterward by Ambrose Bierce
especially, of how this sneak
attack had caught them literally
around their tents in the
morning making coffee,
some of them without their
pants on.
The first day at Shiloh was a
complete Confederate victory.
It drove the Union forces right
back to the river,
the Tennessee River,
and by the time Grant and one
of his other generals,
William Tecumseh Sherman,
arrived that night they found
remnants of this completely
defeated Union force hiding on
the banks of the Tennessee
River,
many of them having lost their
regiments, lost their command,
lost their officers,
didn't know where they were.
Through the dark of night April
6 to 7, it was especially
Sherman and other officers--as
Don Carlos Buell's 20,000 men
arrived at Shiloh in the middle
of that night--Sherman and other
officers,
literally at times,
whipped Union soldiers into
order, tried to help men find
their units.
And when dawn came the next day
they counter-attacked across the
same fields in savage
hand-to-hand combat that all of
these soldiers had never
experienced and never seen.
And by the end of it they
completely reversed the first
day's action.
The Battle of Shiloh took place
in an area about a mile to a
mile and a half in diameter,
and by the end of the second
day, as Grant famously put it in
one of the very few moments in
his two-volume memoir where he
ever kind of really broke down
and described the carnage,
he said, "I could've walked
across that field as far as the
eye could see and never touched
the ground by walking on the
bodies."
For the two armies in
forty-eight hours there were
23,841 casualties;
23,841 casualties.
Now, Shiloh strategically was a
Union success in the simple fact
that the Confederate Army had to
retreat back into Mississippi,
and did not succeed in
re-entering Tennessee and
opening up a new front in
Tennessee,
or taking control of the
Tennessee River in that region.
But it was truly a shock to the
country when these casualty
lists came back and were
published in newspapers,
and when the adjutants of
regiments--which was the job of
an adjutant in a regiment was to
record the casualties and send
them home.
And it was, of course,
that site where Grant
remembered realizing for the
first time--and I had that quote
up here the other day and you
can read it in Gienapp--where he
said,
"It was at that moment I
realized that this war could
never--that the Union could
never be preserved without" what
he called "complete conquest of
the South."
That's what Bruce Catton meant
about how the scabbard was being
thrown away.
It was now a war where no one
would ever call retreat.
Now, back east,
back to the melodrama between
McClellan and Lincoln.
No, that's not the one I want,
excuse me.
I think you can see enough of
this, I hope.
Now McClellan throughout that
winter kept training,
training, and training the Army
of the Potomac.
And he did train them in to
what many military historians
still say was one of the most
efficient and certainly the best
supplied armies the world had
ever seen.
He would have almost 100,000
troops--he'd have 90,000 in the
field--100,000 troops under his
command.
And he came up with a plan that
Lincoln hated;
Edwin Stanton,
Secretary of War,
didn't like it;
officers around him didn't
particularly like it.
But it was McClellan's idea.
McClellan did not want to
invade Virginia from the north.
He thought it would be a better
idea to sail the entire Army of
the Potomac down the Potomac
River out into Chesapeake Bay
and land on the peninsula
between the York and the James
Rivers in Virginia,
and invade Virginia,
toward Richmond,
the capital of the Confederacy.
Take the enemy's capital,
was his aim here--a strategy
eventually that Ulysses S.
Grant is going to tear to
shreds, and quickly realize,
as he was realizing out in the
West,
that the Confederacy was its
armies--not its capital,
not a city here,
a town there.
The idea was to land this huge
flotilla of an army on the coast
and march it sixty,
seventy miles inland and attack
Richmond from the east.
Now, part of the theory here
was that the Confederacy had
been fortifying the north side
of Richmond but maybe not the
east side.
Now, it's no surprise folks,
if you float 90,000 people down
the river and land them on the
coast that you might be coming
from the east.
Lo and behold.
But this is where--I don't want
to make McClellan into just
comic relief like Burns does;
I think he overdoes it--but
here it is important to
understand that generals did
have impact on this war.
It was not that McClellan had a
personal distaste for battle
necessarily;
those charges that he was
somehow a coward and all that,
I don't think that holds up at
all.
But he did not like huge
general engagements,
he did not want to sacrifice
any more men than he had to.
And remember,
he doesn't want the war to
become remorseless.
He put the town of Yorktown,
on the coast--the same Yorktown
where Cornwallis had surrendered
to George Washington in the
American Revolution--he put
Yorktown under siege when he
landed,
for an entire month,
from April 5 to May 4,
because McClellan was convinced
that he was confronted with far
more men than he really was.
At one point McClellan actually
wrote a dispatch to Secretary of
War Stanton claiming that he was
facing on the peninsula at least
200,000 Confederates.
There weren't 200,000
Confederates under arms anywhere
in the South,
in 1862.
But McClellan was always
overestimating his enemy.
He hired the Pinkerton
detectives.
He hired this guy named Lowe
with his balloons;
this was the first use of
balloons in warfare.
They'd float these things up in
the air and they'd go and they'd
float over the enemy and they'd
try to count the forces and
they'd hope the wind was right
to float them back and land
them.
They were pretty cumbersome,
awful;
and one time the thing floated
and it crashed in the other side
of the Confederate troops.
He was getting his intelligence
from all these new modern ways,
and every time he got
intelligence it's apparent that
McClellan would just start doing
some multiplication.
Oh, and there's so many stories
about this;
I'll spare you.
He didn't need to put Yorktown
under siege for a month,
he could've taken it in 48
hours.
The Confederates had built a
lot of fortifications,
huge fortifications,
but they didn't have very many
men behind it.
And where one officer might see
one Confederate in a
field-glass, McClellan would see
five or 10.
Given this caution,
given this slowness,
the Confederate command in
Richmond sent the young General
Stonewall Jackson with about
20,000 men over to the
Shenandoah Valley,
here.
While McClellan had landed this
massive army on the peninsula
and it was slowly beginning to
move,
they send Stonewall Jackson
with an army of about 20,000 men
to the Shenandoah Valley,
where Stonewall Jackson
conducted one of the most famous
military campaigns in
history--and they still teach
this in minute detail at West
Point.
Actually he only had about
17,000 men.
The purpose of this was to
throw fear into northern
Virginia, fear into the capital
at Washington,
and to keep about 30,000 Union
troops in Northern Virginia,
that McClellan had left behind.
The idea here was that
McClellan would move from the
east, 30,000,
roughly, Union troops would
move from the north,
and they would crush Richmond
from two sides,
and the war would be over by
July.
The Confederates saw this and
they said, all right.
Jackson spent the period April
29 to June 5,
five weeks roughly,
marching all up and down the
Shenandoah Valley,
driving his men to utter
exhaustion, twenty and
twenty-five miles a day.
He fought five major battles,
marched 400 miles in those five
weeks, fought lots of kind of
contact,
rearguard actions,
eluded three different Union
armies or parts of Union armies
at various times,
threw fear into Washington,
kept the 30,000 Union troops
all occupied in Northern
Virginia and Western Virginia,
and then escaped,
back down the valley and back
to Richmond, by the time
McClellan attacked.
It was an extraordinary
campaign.
It made Stonewall Jackson's
fame.
Now, the first major contact
finally between the Union forces
and Confederate forces on the
peninsula came at a place called
Seven Pines or Fair Oaks.
It's a place about some six,
seven miles east of Richmond.
It would be the first major
bloody affair for this Army of
the Potomac.
And I want to describe it for
you by simply reading excerpts
from a few letters,
of a Union soldier,
leading up to the moment of his
first major battle.
And I want to do this in part
because we need to
understand--and we'll come back
to this question a bit
later--that what a common
soldier out there in the field
understands about what is
happening is,
of course, almost always a blur;
it's the fog of war that he
sees.
I had the opportunity about,
oh God, fifteen years ago now,
to edit a collection of Civil
War letters that were lopped in
my lap by a young soldier from
Massachusetts named Charles
Brewster.
Charlie Brewster was a store
clerk in Northampton,
Massachusetts when the Civil
War broke out in April of '61.
He was 27-years-old,
he felt like a total failure in
life.
He was not yet married.
He had nothing going on.
And he enlisted as fast as he
could in the 10^(th)
Massachusetts,
and he spent that whole fall
and winter of '61/'62 in camp.
And I will mention Charlie
again next week,
because Charlie was no
abolitionist,
trust me, but he comes to
realize through this experience
that the war has to destroy
slavery.
It's an interesting model of
the average Yankee.
But he wrote incredible
letters, always to his mother or
his sister.
He writes this on May--Battle
of Fair Oaks or Seven Pines
occurred on May 31 of 1862.
He knows a big battle's coming.
They don't know exactly where
or when.
It is raining like hell.
He's sleeping in the mud on
what he calls a rubber blanket.
He gets diarrhea that nearly is
killing him, and he will almost
die of diarrhea twice in this
war.
But he keeps writing to his
mother.
And one morning the rain has
stopped and he tells her what a
beautiful morning it is.
"Mother, I wish you could see
what a splendid morning this is.
The trees are in full foliage
and the birds are singing in the
trees and the water ripples and
sparks at my feet,
with the sun shining gloriously
over all.
And if it were not for the
regiment I see before me,
each with his deadly end-field
rifle on his shoulder,
I could hardly imagine that
there was a war anywhere in the
land."
Now, day by day--he writes
every day to his mother,
long letters.
Some of these letters
handwritten were fifteen to
twenty page letters,
and he wrote about 240 of them,
in the course of the war.
May 22, in a clover field,
he says: "Dear Mother,
it is just sunset,
a most beautiful day,
though it has been dreadful
hot.
I was relieved this morning
from my guard duty,
at General Keyes' headquarters,
and joined the regiment and
immediately took up my line of
march with them.
We came on about two miles,
or perhaps not quite as far as
that, and bivouacked in this
field.
It's the best place we have had
since we left Warwick.
Our small brigade is in the
advance and we go out on picket
frequently.
We do not know anything of what
is going on in the world outside
of our camp.
How I wish I could see a late
paper.
We've got a rumor that there's
been a battle out in Corinth,
Mississippi,
and that Beauregard and 23,000
men are prisoners,
but I presume there is no truth
in it.
Our artillery had a skirmish
last night, in a swamp in the
front.
We're expecting a great battle
Mom, but I reckon that Little
Mac will make his dispositions
for it and the chivalry"--which
means the South--"will take a
distant view of his preparations
and then skedaddle,
as usual.
If they don't they will get a
terrible licking,
though it is reported that they
are concentrating everything
there and have got 140,000
troops.
A contraband"--meaning an
escaped slave--"that came in
yesterday says that they are
talking terrible fierce about
burning Richmond,
fighting over the ashes.
But I think that's all bosh."
Thursday morning,
May 23: "On picket," he says.
"Dear Mother,
Captain and myself slept under
the same blanket last night and
on the ground in front of the
muskets,
and it was harder than
Pharaoh's heart.
But it promotes early rising,
for it's now 7 a.m.
and I've been up for three
hours."
"In an oat field,
Saturday, May 24.
I had the best view of the army
in motion there that I ever had
as they came down a long slope
of low hills to the creek and
then up the other side,
and as we arrived at the top of
the latter slope I turned and
took a look back and could see
the long line,
looking like an enormous snake
winding back for two and three
miles, and bristling with
bayonets,
and at a short distance the
Stars and Stripes and the flags
of different states and the
guidons,
presenting a scene that occurs
but once in a great while.
It is raining like great guns
again and the order has come to
pack up and move on."
"Oh dear Mother,"--this is the
next day--"A large mail has come
and everybody has got something
but me.
I cannot write any more under
such circumstances.
So goodbye, my love to all.
[Laughter]
And if you can,
any of you, spare time,
please write me a letter.
[Laughter] Love, Charlie."
Wednesday, May 28^(th).
"Dear Mother,
Today the sun shines brightly
and it is brazen hot.
But at half past two this
company has got to go out and
dig in the trenches for two
hours.
One thing is very certain,
if they do not take Richmond
soon they will kill the whole
army by this ceaseless exposure
and toil."
May 31^(st),
the day of the Battle of Seven
Pines.
"Mother, and now in relation to
the coming battle,
if anything should happen and I
should get killed,
you will be entitled to my pay.
There is three months due me,
but if I should not get paid
off before anything should
happen, my pay will be in two
places;
that is from the
March"--meaning the
month--"there will be fifty
dollars per month in the State
Treasury of Massachusetts,
which I have allotted there
subject to my own order.
The rest of my pay is drawn
from the U.S.
Paymaster, as usual."
Imagine being his mother.
And then it's this letter after
the battle.
"June 2,1862,
six miles from Richmond.
Dear Mother,
I presume this letter will find
you most anxious,
expecting a letter from me.
I'm sitting in the hot sun and
can write you but a few lines.
Oh Mother, I cannot begin to
give you any idea of the
terrific storm of bullets,
shot and shell,
that poured over us as we lay
behind those pits.
We could not get into them for
they were full of brine of
water, but we lay right behind
them in the mud.
After half an hour of this the
firing ceased and we were
ordered forward behind some
fallen woods."
And then he goes on to describe
how they were attacked from the
rear and how he heard the
bullets flying by him
constantly,
and how he considers it a
miracle that he is alive.
And then at the very end of
this letter: "I cannot succeed
in giving you any idea of
battle.
But I know this much,
that I had no possible hope of
coming out alive.
And I thought it all over,
how terribly you would feel,
and all that.
But I came out without a
scratch.
I look back upon it and I
cannot think how it can be.
It does not seem as though any
man that had been there could
come out unhurt."
Then he begins to describe his
friends and buddies who were
killed, by name,
how they were killed,
where they were shot.
And he ends,
"There are so many incidents
crowding my head Mother,
that I cannot write clearly at
all.
And even when I sleep,
the minute I get into a doze,
I hear the whistling of the
shells and the shouts and the
groans.
And to sum it up in two words,
it is horrible."
Charlie will survive the war.
He nearly died of dysentery
twice.
He had two horses shot out from
under him.
He was deeply proud of his
commission as a Second
Lieutenant and as an adjutant of
his regiment.
His regiment was devastated.
There were so few men left by
July of 1864,
they were disbanded.
He went home to Massachusetts.
He couldn't imagine being a
civilian.
He hated civilians.
He re-enlisted to be a
recruiter of black soldiers.
This racist young man from
western Massachusetts,
who will freely use the word
"nigger,"
was employed from August of
1864 through the end of the war
recruiting black men in Norfolk,
Virginia, and his principle job
was sitting in an office writing
love letters for illiterate
black women,
to their husbands at the front,
whom he thanks for teaching him
the art of love-letter writing.
Well, the battle of the
peninsula ended up in what's
called the Seven Days.
The Battle of the Seven Days
were the battles fought all
around Richmond,
from June 25^(th) through July
1^(st),
seven consecutive days;
places called Mechanicsville,
Gaines Mill,
Savage Station,
Frazier's Farm,
Malvern Hill.
They're all little
crossroads--they're not even
really villages anymore--that
are just east of Richmond.
It was sustained,
day-to-day fighting.
Both sides suffered horrible
casualties.
The result was essentially the
fact that McClellan did not
succeed in taking Richmond;
in fact, on the contrary,
McClellan's forces were forced
down south of Richmond to the
edge of the James River to a
place called Malvern Hill where
McClellan put his wounded,
damaged army into camp for too
long.
The Battle of the Seven Days
saved Richmond,
it saved the Confederacy.
It also brought Robert E.
Lee into the command of all
Confederate forces in the
eastern theater of the war,
because Joseph E.
Johnston, who had been in
command of the Confederate
forces, was wounded on the first
day of the Seven Days,
and Jefferson Davis put Lee in
command.
And it was in some ways Lee's
aggressiveness in the Seven Days
that actually won that affair.
And now Lee made the first
fateful decision of the war,
for him.
After many consultations with
Jefferson Davis and his other
commanders, he made the decision
to invade the North.
And this was fateful,
to say the least,
and it will bring us to the
first major turning point of the
Civil War.
I've just run the clock out,
I fear.
Oh damn.
I have two minutes.
Let me leave you here.
The idea Lee had,
and it's not that complicated,
is that the war was now
devastating Virginia.
Richmond was all but under
siege.
The theory here was take the
war to the North,
take the war out of Virginia,
take the war to northern soil,
hopefully get into Maryland.
And he believed there were
thousands of Maryland men who
would come to the Confederate
standard, if they saw the
Confederate Army.
Threaten the capital,
Washington, DC;
threaten Philadelphia and
Pennsylvania;
threaten the North,
take the war to their soil,
to their farms,
to their homes.
And strategically--and this is
where Jefferson Davis agreed
with him, although he was very
leery about this--a strike into
the North that could win a major
victory on northern soil and
threaten the Union capital,
possibly even enforce an
evacuation of the Federal
capital, might bring the most
important thing the Confederacy
needed--and they were on the
verge of it--and that was
British intervention,
British recognition and
intervention on the side of the
Confederacy.
I'll discuss that possible
intervention more as a piece of
how emancipation becomes the
result of this Antietam campaign
next week.
But let me leave you here.
Lee decides in the face of a
kind of quiescent McClellan to
leave only a small force in
Richmond, and move north into
Virginia and invade the north.
McClellan's army,
having suffered 20,000
casualties in the Seven Days,
is not going to move,
and he's not going to move
until he absolutely has to.
It is the first great daring
move of the war.
It will fail,
but it nearly succeeded.
And the reason Antietam is the
first major turning point of
this war is not just because of
the decisive battle they fought
on the Maryland side of the
Potomac,
but because it will be the
occasion to allow Abraham
Lincoln to do what he'd been
planning to do through much of
that summer,
and Congress had been prodding
him to do, which was to announce
to the world that this was a war
to free the slaves.
See you next week.